picking someone to take over a role from
another actor
is never easy especially when the
original performer drew praise for their
take on that character
but recasting is often unavoidable
especially for sequels and remakes
here are some more role replacements
that ruined movies
roger moore and sean connery each made
seven appearances as james bond though
many double 07 fans will tell you that
connery is the only bond
a cbs news poll concluded that 51
of americans chose connery as their
favorite bond with pierce brosnan
coming in a distant second george lesnbe
the man who replaced connery in the role
for 1969's on her majesty's secret
service received just one percent of the
vote which tells you
everything you need to know about the
gulf between these two actors
while critical opinion toward the film
itself has softened over time
lazenby's performance is still a bone of
contention
inevitably compared to those delivered
by connery in the franchise's five
previous entries the chicago reader said
that george lesinbee
has so much reserve as james bond that
he makes sean connery seem almost
frenetic by comparison reviews in the uk
were just as critical of the leading
man's turn as the british
secret service agent with london-based
outlet time
out calling him a stunning non-entity
fronting a film
with no redeeming features following in
the footsteps of linda hamilton
as sarah connor in the terminator
franchise was never going to be easy
she gave a performance so layered and
compelling that even the most
talented of actresses would have
struggled to do the character justice
a volunteer why
there's a chance to meet the legend
sarah connor the first to give it a shot
was lena heady who was cast as the
titular heroine
in the short-lived tv series terminator
the sarah connor chronicles
fox canceled the show after two seasons
leaving hidy's game of thrones colleague
emilia clark to carry the torch
2015's terminator genesis was heavily
criticized for using that old
time travel chestnut to rewrite the
beginning of the terminator story to
suit the filmmaker's purposes
the main problem however wasn't the
infuriatingly muddled timeline it was
the casting
veteran film critic peter bradshaw
dressed down the whole main cast in his
one star review for the guardian calling
amelia clark's take on connor
uninteresting 1981's the clash of the
titans attempted to give greek mythology
the star wars treatment
taking the story of perseus and turning
it into a sprawling epic
director desmond davis went with harry
hamlin in the role of perseus a son of
zeus who in legend beheads the gorgon
medusa in order to save his beloved
princess andromeda from a giant kraken
hamlin remains active in the industry
though he's still arguably best
remembered for his turn as perseus
the same cannot be said for sam
worthington best known as the star of
james cameron's budding avatar franchise
director louis leteriae entrusted the
australian with the lead role in his
2010 remake though his choice was called
into question when the negative reviews
started to pour in
worthington's earned his share of a
claim over the years but the titans
remake is one release he most likely
wouldn't mind leaving off his resume
quickflix's simon morado
questioned how worthington had ever
managed to become a hollywood actor
after watching his performance as
perseus in which
he does nothing but glare his battle
speeches are neither rousing nor
particularly intelligible despite its
name 1984's friday the 13th part for the
final chapter was far from the last
installment in this long-running horror
franchise in fact eight more films have
been made since the so-called final
chapter though the one that directly
followed it marked a major drop-off in
quality
part 4 has been described as one of the
last really excellent horror romps that
focus
on character dynamic and family felix
vasquez of cinema crazed
praised corey feldman for his standout
performance as young tommy jarvis
feldman went on to make a name for
himself in the goonies stand by me and
the lost boys though before he did he
reprised his friday the 13th role in
1985's part 5 a new beginning
unfortunately he only appeared in the
prologue and a time jump meant he was
replaced by the painfully dull john
shepard
teenage tommy was static compared to his
younger self though
shepard shouldn't shoulder the blame
entirely some blamed what they called
the ham-fisted directing of david
steinman while james kendrick of q
network argued that
the gory antics are so restrained by the
insistence of the mpaa rating system
that the film
feels like it was edited with one of
jason's bloody rusty weapons
wesley snipes rejected the opportunity
to return as willie mays hayes in 1994's
major league two
because he had become a movie star in
his own right by then with the cleveland
indians down a man
the filmmakers turned to omar epps
director david
s ward had worked with epps on the
program the previous year
which was a sports movie following the
exploits of a college football team
the big difference between the two films
however was that the program wasn't
meant to be funny
epps didn't have a background in comedy
and it showed in his timing
even those who didn't think the film was
all that bad admitted that
omar epps taking over for wesley snipes
was a complete
bomb of a decision bad all around
veteran film critic mark kermode summed
up 2015's the transporter refueled with
a single question
what exactly is the point of a
transporter movie without jason statham
when it was revealed that ed sprin was
to replace statham as special forces op
turned private driver frank martin in
the fourth transporter film
questions were raised about the former's
ability to carry the franchise forward
though the transporter films didn't
exactly change the action movie
landscape they benefited from statham's
presence athletic prowess and combat
skills
his replacement lacked that experience
and it showed skren began taking classes
in various martial arts disciplines as
he prepared for both the transporter
refueled and his role as ajax in
deadpool but
even he acknowledged that he was way
behind many of his peers in that
department
he told the bbc i'm very respectful and
realize i'm not going to be able to do
things meant for 10 or 20 years of
training
the action in the transporter refueled
was ultimately limited by the nustar's
fledgling abilities
ed skrinn's one and only outing as frank
martin was a commercial and critical
flop
that left the luke basson produced
franchise dead in the water
rooney mara took the role of androgynous
computer hacker liz beth salander
starring opposite daniel craig in 2011's
the girl with the dragon tattoo when the
2018 sequel the girl in the spider's web
was announced
fans of david fincher's critically
acclaimed first film were a little
disappointed that both mara and craig
had been recast
and so was mera she told yahoo i was
hopeful to come back
but they decided to do a different thing
it was always a character i wanted to
revisit but that's not what happened
severe goodness and replaced daniel
craig while claire foy stepped into the
pale
pierced skin of cylander unfortunately
she didn't look comfortable in it at the
time she was receiving a claim for her
turn as the young queen elizabeth ii
in the crown but foy couldn't pull off
salander's cold eccentricities with the
same poise as her predecessor
critics were by and large unimpressed
with her version of the goth hacker with
many questioning why she was chosen for
the part
the observers wendy eyde said much as i
admire her
foy is miscast here she's just too
empathetic for a role that requires an
almost reptilian lack of emotion
indie wires senior film critic david
ehrlich called her both
terrible and terribly miscast the first
robocop stars peter weller as the
titular cyborg
he roams a dystopian crime ridden
version of detroit mercilessly dealing
with lawbreakers
weller reprised the role in robocop 2
but turned down the chance to play him
again in a third movie
producers needed a replacement and their
hearts were apparently set on a
little-known actor named robert john
burke
in a 2015 interview burke said in god's
great earth they thought i was the only
actor who could do it
i don't know why i think physically i
poked like peter weller and i had also
had
extensive karate training pantomime
training and body training and i fit the
suit
unsurprisingly handing the lead role
over to the relatively inexperienced
perk just because he kind of resembled
weller didn't work out very well
he may have looked like him in the suit
but as the new york times said in its
review of the box office
bomb burke is lacking his forerunners
tongue-in-cheek glint of authoritarian
machismo
you have the right to an attorney what
is it
from his delivery to the way he moved
burke just wasn't as convincing as
robocop
as empire noted he appeared to be a lot
less comfortable with the hardware
1988's big is often cited as tom hanks
breakout movie but he actually announced
himself as a potential star some four
years earlier in ron howard's fantasy
rom-com
splash hanks plays alan bauer a young
man who returns to the spot of what he
believes was a near-death hallucination
to discover that the woman he saw in the
water the day he almost drowned is
indeed real
allen falls for mermaid madison and
ditches his life on land to live
under the sea with her in a goofy yet
undeniably feel-good ending
it's a beloved movie though the same
cannot be said about the obscure made
for tv sequel
splash 2. helmed by writer director and
actor greg
antonacci the highly forgettable and
completely unnecessary splash 2 brought
allen and madison back to dry land
totally ignoring the fact that the
government wanted to lock her up in a
lab in the previous installment
todd waring took over as alan bauer but
despite his best efforts
he lacked the every man charm and
comedic timing that was abundant in
hank's
filmfad said in its review of the sequel
the less said about the actors replacing
tom hanks and john candy the better
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one